CATHERINE DRENNAN: The
idea was in a big class
of like 300 students,
most of the students
are not going to have
an opportunity really
to meet the professors.
They may go to office hours,
but even then, the office hours,
you can't schedule your
office hours at a time
where all 300 people in
the class are available.
So you'll just get
to know maybe a few.
But with the pizza
forums, they're
every few weeks
during the semester,
and we encourage
at least one person
from each recitation to come.
And it's just a way
for the students
to get to know the
faculty and vice versa.
And sometimes we discuss things
about chemistry, you know,
especially if people
have suggestions of what
they like and don't like.
But a lot of times, they're just
talking about their experiences
at MIT.
And there have been some
really useful things,
I think, for the course
that have come out
of it, like learning,
for example,
that we had our problems
sets due at the same time
as pretty much all of
their other classes.
So we moved it to a different
day because that made no sense.
And also, kind of some of
the educational ways-- what
clickers they're using,
how they like them.
We heard some horrible
things about clickers
that had been used in physics.
And so then they
started to change them.
And when we looked
at clickers, we
learned from the
physics experience.
But it really came through
knowing that from the students,
rather than talking
to the other faculty.
We had sort of heard what
worked and didn't work.
So having those kind of
direct conversations.
And they feel like they're
representing the student
body in saying, oh
we like this, or we
don't like that,
or have you thought
about doing something this way.
And it's just also a lot of fun.
And everyone goes around
and says where they're from.
I love to ask them, what
is one thing about MIT
that is exactly
what you expected
and what's one thing
that really surprised you
when you got here?
And I just find it
really interesting
to see what people said.
And I often get, I expected
everyone to be smart,
everybody is smart.
I expected everyone to
be just more serious,
but people are fun
and nice and silly
and they're kind of
like normal people
and that sort of surprised me.
So that is always a
lot of fun to hear that
and get to know them.